hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well Aristotle's
ethics is articulated otha monicker
mechanics and in his works more widely
is a variety of moral theory that we
call virtue ethics and there's often
quite a bit of misunderstanding when
people first begin studying virtue
ethics that I think is clarified by the
topic that we're going to talk about
here which is how virtue acts as a norm
for moral evaluation here's where the
puzzle comes in for people who are not
virtue ethicists we're not you know
working implicitly within that that set
of traditions when we come to ethics
from the outside we will often assume
that what's really key is evaluation and
just evaluation of actions or perhaps
actions and intentions or policies for
virtue ethics it's not quite so simple
as that and many people get into trouble
because they they look at other ethics
which at least in the textbook
formulation of them not necessarily the
actual formulation and people's worst
seem to be fairly straightforward can be
reduced to some clear axiom
from which then we you know spit out an
entire ethics allowing you know decision
procedures and you know that sort of
thing virtue ethics doesn't permit that
and I'm going to actually make an
assignment others doesn't permit that in
part because virtue ethics is actually
closer to the truth than these other
ethics because more life is quite
complicated and moral phenomena often
turn out to be ambiguous many-sided
requiring prudence in order to make
sense of but we're going to talk about
that in another video here or we're
particularly interested in is how the
virtues themselves function as moral
norms and what are the virtues let's
start out with that so the virtues as
Aristotle understands them this is not
as definition but it's a very good
characterization are determinate modes
of human excellence so there are
multiple versions there is justice which
is something different than temperance
which is something different than good
temper which is something different than
we can keep going through the entire
list of the virtues these are
established character traits that have
developed within a person perhaps in
part from training but primarily this is
what training would fall under through
habituation through doing the certain
kind of action or in terms of the
virtues that have to do more with our
management of emotions with responding
in certain ways there's much more to the
picture than that you know other
people's models function Forest plays
plays into that but that's going to fit
here as well so these determinants molds
of human excellence move us towards our
fundamental good which is flourishing
and Aristotle conceives of happiness as
being a life of virtuous activity life
that actually engages the virtues which
means that we would actually have to
have the virtues so you can see that in
virtue ethics one way of answering the
question well what is the good
what is what we ought to take into
account when making moral decisions is
well the virtues are good the virtues
are a set of goods that it would be good
for us to have and thereby good for us
to cultivate and that helps to answer
some of how virtue works as a norm for
evaluation because you can think to
yourself okay well I don't have
temperance yet what would it take for me
to actually be temperate it would be
good for me to be tempered so that's a
criterion right there but one of the
things that would be means to that end
of acquiring temperance well maybe
cutting back on my food intake you know
regulating the times that I allow myself
to have a snack instead of saying well I
feel like having a snack so this
Catholic write that as a matter of fact
there's a choice there and if I choose
the wrong mode I'm actually probably
choosing what's going to leave me
towards a vice the one of the vice is
opposed to them emerging so that
provides a norm for a moral evaluation
we want to do what will lead us towards
virtue but in Aristotle you know gives
us a lot more than that so one of the
key distinctions that is going to make
is that we can find running throughout
his worst is acting in accordance with
virtue or a virtue and acting from an
established state of virtue that one
already has what would be an example of
this difference let's pick temperance or
moderation in bottom of the appetites
for an example drinking a person may
decide you know I've really been
partying too much and I need to cut back
on my my consumption of alcohol I
understand that you know it makes me the
life of the party but it's got some
deleterious effects on me I really don't
like this feeling not not the feeling of
being drunk and out of control but the
feeling of not actually having control
over my own appetites my
own decisions my own pursuit of pleasure
I'd like to have a bit more of that
control in my life so what do they do
they model themselves after people who
actually do in fact have that virtue of
temperance I said well I should act like
that guy and so you know for example if
they're out really late yeah at the bar
and they've got a good buzz going and it
comes to last call there's that that you
know tendency for people to say I'm
going to find myself a couple drinks
because I would really want to you know
make sure that I'm well provided for
them well no perhaps you don't need to
do that perhaps you observe that guy
over there who typically doesn't go out
for that much but it's out for say the
Christmas party and his is you know it's
last call he says I've had enough that's
that's a measured amount per for myself
with in this situation then you look at
under the rest of the week and he's not
you know going out and drinking at home
and all that he saved it for a special
occasion where it's going to promote
some sort of good committee ality or
something along those lines or per guest
the person who has one glass of wine
with dinner rather than saying well I
open the bottle so I probably should you
know shouldn't let this wine to go to
waste has helped in some justifications
so that person is modeling their actions
in accordance with virtue on a person
who actually does have the virtue and it
may be a specific person who they use as
a role model or maybe a set of
guidelines that they found it in some
sort of book written by somebody who
knows something about virtue it might be
a composite picture put together lots of
different sources but there is a
fundamental difference between not
counting the virtue but acting in
accordance with virtues and then acting
from what one actually
as a resource within oneself Arizona
will talk about this in book 2 chapter 4
he uses the examples of temperance and
justice there we're going to make a
little bit more generic uses actions are
right they call virtues when they are of
the sort that virtuous people do so just
actions are the kinds of actions that
people who actually have the virtue of
justice do right you know there sounds a
little bit circular when we say it in
the abstract but when we make it
concrete and we look at how just people
actually behave we have criteria for
that era so we'll talk about this in
book 5 he'll go into great detail same
thing with temperance I was going to
talk about that in book 3 there are some
guidelines for this so the action itself
can be virtuous that if it's a virtuous
action is that action in accordance with
virtue we're talking about moral
evaluation it's a good action a bad
person can engage in a good action an
action that doesn't display virtue
because they don't have virtue but which
if they did long enough would actually
start making them move away from vice or
you know lack of self-control to virtue
it's still good quality action in that
particular situation so if I'm normally
a stingy guy but I show I engage in an
action that appears to be a rather
generous one by certain measures perhaps
because I want to get in good with
somebody it's still a good action
insofar as it is in accordance with
version we can say the same thing too by
the way about vicious actions there is a
big difference between being a vicious
person somebody who has a vicious
disposition with respect to a particular
some goods or emotional responses or
actions and just being somebody who does
vicious actions but again if you do them
long enough you will become vicious so
you know engaging in actions of
intemperance you mean that yourself
already
have the vice of intemperance
established within your soul or your
personality but you can do actions that
are indeed in temperate right or unjust
or cowardly or you know displaying bad
temper all of these are possibilities
and we use the virtues then as norms for
evaluation in saying whether an action
is of this sort and whether it's going
to be now Aristotle clarifies this a bit
though it may not seem like a
clarification to you in this particular
sentence but if you tie in and all the
other things that go into virtue it
becomes so he says actions are rarely
called virtuous when all the sort of
virtuous people do but the person the
person engaging in the action is
virtuous only if they do those actions
in the way that virtuous people do them
the Greek there is host which means in
this kind of manner or this kind of way
so what actually goes into that these
are the things that we're going to touch
on other videos in this core concepts
series well one is all those rights that
go into establishing the mean you know
the feeling for example in emotion at
the right time towards the right people
for the right reasons you know engaging
in actions for instance with generosity
what do you spend your your resources on
do you do it in order to be a big shot
do you do it because you can't say no to
people that's a vice that do you do it
because you want to conduce to the
general good or the good of the people
that you care about that's that's
virtuous provided you're not being
stingy you know withholding too much or
giving too much giving people things
that really aren't good for them is not
an example of generosity for harris off
so that's part of that that hosts that
that in the way but another aspect of
this is that the virtuous person
willingly does what is virtuous because
they want to do it
because they identify that with who they
are so you know when you're on a diet
for example or first engaging and
exercise you're trying to get your body
back in shape you don't enjoy it okay
trust me I'm talking from much
experience here but if you stick with it
long enough then you begin to enjoy it
because you're establishing new habits
now those habits our virtues eventually
you get to the point where part of that
in that way is that you naturally steer
towards being generous or being just or
being truthful those things become part
of the fabric of who you are likewise we
can say the same thing about vicious
people a vicious a vicious person
commits vicious actions in the way that
vicious people do they the light it in
vice whereas somebody else may do
something bad and still feel bad about
it afterwards or while they're doing it
and think this really isn't the right
thing I have to do it at the time they
would not be doing it in the way that
vicious people do it so you see how
virtue and the virtues operate as a very
robust and flexible norm for moral
evaluation within Aristotle's ethics